oh it's it's there's a jet right here
come on come on come on come on don't
shoot me don't shoot me don't shoot me
don't shoot
oh man laughter all right behind you huh
well they think I'm a cop too it's okay
G not gonna get in don't worry I got
this seated I got this though no problem
the rain is too slippery you just hear
explosions now in a minute than these
just shy piece of [ __ ]
see you struggling I'm calling the dump
truck don't worry Oh goddess please
please please
bro come on come on when there's no
people around I knew it this is my one
chance in life that's just a minute oh
god yeah I'm gonna hit that thing okay
I am in one but wait wait wait Felix
wait wait let me in are you went in you
and I rate myself oh wow I'm gonna try
to get up with that stupid [ __ ] [ __ ]
that man Oh get wing buddy when you buy
those yeah yeah you know it's just gonna
get you killed hope you know well known
is TMJ
do listen to him Jerry
okay how do I steer away from that
this guy with a helicopter Sam yeah I
made a helicopter did you jump out yeah
[ __ ] cops
I just keep stopping up here is the
streaker we see him running across the
street
not even kid yeah beautiful work it girl
oh great
let's go okay do you want me to bring
you in and drop you at a jet yes please
okay tell me when is right there's Jack
I Drive her company's gone [ __ ] sake
really yep on the roof oh good going
down
oh [ __ ] No oh thanks
we're gonna get out of your jack yeah
yes
stop I can show you a world
y-yeah well yes didn't know all right